good morning Ross how are you morning
Dan doing great thanks can you sum up
sort of when you got that feeling that
this was going to be a different game
different Vikings team showing up last
night probably not until you know fools
hit the bomb to house on Jeffery and the
Eagle started you know when was 21-7
because before that was right after the
Derek Barnett strip sack of keenum
because up until that point I mean the
Vikings marched on that first drive I
thought the Eagles might be in trouble
and I still wonder what would have
happened and again I wish we could have
an alternate reality and see what
happened in that game if Chris Long
doesn't hit Keenan's arm and lead to the
pick six for Patrick Robinson but after
that it just seemed like it went all
downhill for the Vikings I've seen some
of the quotes from Terrence Newman a
former teammate of mine other guys Kenny
had no energy or no life and maybe
that's a carryover from what happened
the week before but I would have thought
Dan if that was a carryover that that
would be reflected in the start of the
game and it was it I mean the Vikings
marched right down the field yeah and
then it's all of a sudden you had to
pick six and then all of a sudden you
had the the touchdown I I thought the
Torrey Smith touchdown was the one that
was sort of like uh-oh you guys are you
guys are in for a long long night here
yeah I just can't believe what I saw you
know I live outside of Philadelphia grew
up here so I watched every snap at our
Eagles game and it's unbelievable banned
how bad Nick Foles was against the
Raiders and the Cowboys and then for him
to play that well I mean he really he
really did look like Carson Wentz last
night he made Carson Wentz type of plays
it's incredible man he's got to be up
there when you think about the 2013
season he had and they're like what do
you do with the Rams a couple years
later he's up there in terms of the
all-time check on high quarterback in
NFL history because he's got his eyes
are really high and his lows are really
low as a former NFL offensive lineman
tell me what you see with that defensive
front with the Eagles and what you think
how they play that when they
face New England well it's what's so
impressive about them and why I think an
early tip here is that the Patriots will
do a lot of no huddle is that it's their
depth it's that they just come in you
and wait I mean Chris Long doesn't even
start you know so if you are Bill
Belichick and Tom Brady and the Vikings
tried to do this a little bit at times
last night what makes them so special is
that they bring the guys in and waves
and I can remember even when I was in
New England II was in Buffalo and we had
a good defensive line with Katt Williams
Sam Adams
that used to be fellow second brady's
thing cut a tire out because they don't
have as much depth at D tackle so try to
tire out
Fletcher Cox and Timmy Jernigan and also
not let the Eagle sub when they have
every guy that comes in is that fresh
and that good it just kind of it just
kind of beats you down I don't know if
it's conscious or subconscious but a lot
of times when I was playing Dan he's
bringing it back up like a rotational
guy and you kind of be happy cuz right
okay this guy's not as good as a guy
we're just calling it for the Eagles
there's just there's just no let-up if I
take away Brady and foals and I compare
these two teams now I know you can't do
this on game day but let's just for
entertainment purposes who's got the
better team Philadelphia or New England
if I take away the quarterbacks oh the
Eagles the Eagles especially you know
with no element which by the way is
pretty incredible when the Eagles don't
have their Hall of Fame left tackle you
know their best running back probably in
Sproles their best linebacker I would
argue in Jordan Hicks their best special
teamer and Maragos I mean what what Rose
was done with this roster is incredible
I would say the Eagles I mean they're
better at almost every position probably
in that corner but definitely the Eagles
in my mind the Brady performance that he
said after the fact hey I don't want to
sound arrogant but you know I this
wasn't a big deal but it certainly felt
like a big deal leading up to this game
so how do you rank this Brady
performance yesterday afternoon
I've almost lost track at this point in
you know I kind of reformed just because
I was there and oh five and oh six and I
was his teammate and I mean every time
he does another amazing thing it makes
me a little bit cooler somehow I don't
know I mean eight Super Bowls in 16
years of playing 75% conference
championship games and clearly the
stitches weren't that much of an impact
in but didn't help me it does as a guy
that loves to practice he is the most
intense practice player I ever played
with so the fact that he wasn't able to
practice on Thursday that would drive
him bonkers I mean he would he would
absolutely be feeding about that he's
intense I mean he used to get intense
with me about snapping the ball to him I
mean he'd be like Ross has to be great
every time woody snap I mean you know I
was 26 pins and I've been playing
offensive line since sixth grade and
episode or every practice you snapped
the ball and it's like it's just what
you do it's kind of stupid it's like you
just do it because that's what you do at
practice you didn't want it to be a good
step or a great snap he wanted a perfect
I mean the guy is a total psycho in
every aspect of life and so even if the
stitches you know weren't that big of a
deal I mean it doesn't make it easier it
doesn't make it easier to throw a
football with ten stitches in your hand
or whatever he had would you rather lose
like the Vikings did or the Jags did Wow
I would say like the Vikings did because
because then you could be like man it
just wasn't our day and falls play out
of his mind
the Jags you can actually point to so
many play like in the Jags locker room
and on the plane those guys are all
thinking about that one or two plays
that if they had done something
different they could be playing in the
Super Bowl the Vikings are just drinking
beers being like holy crap that sucked
I'll leave you with this who has a
better chance to stay with their
respective teams Case Keenum or Blake
bortles
Blake bortles III I think well I think
both are both those guys will be with
their teams next year I don't know how
Jacksonville for Minnesota you can get
rid of either one of those guys but I
thought bortles was really impressive
yesterday you know Keenum had his worst
game in a while but portals back-to-back
games against Roethlisberger and Brady
on the road meaning I doesn't throw a
good ball ban but there's more to
playing the quarterback position than
just how pretty your ball is I mean his
playmaking ability and you know the way
he's able to move around I think he
makes up for it I think bortles
is going to be the jagged guy for the
next couple years Thank You Ross we'll
see in Minneapolis absolutely can't wait
there thanks for having me it's Ross
Tucker former lineman now working for
Westwood One also NBC Sports Network
working the NFC title game last night
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]